I mean listen I love VTR to the next
version but I did not pay five dollars
for that room it wait but you know what
I'd pay like a billion dollars for like
some tacos literally in this where
should we go
Taco Bell let's go okay wait Oh your
shoes God I got them are you going I
like shoes not so much today oh my god
talk about the liver yes what do you
want okay let me tell you like a busy
five layer burrito and a crunch and
supreme beef
thanks so much bad Felicity happened I
don't know how you were those around all
night you don't know anything about me
Taco Bell toggle off wait thank you so
much
was I an angel spoo no that's just a
Taco Bell oh my god we got so much oh
it's what I know me too
what do you want can I have an Italian
self with chicken tenders and french
fries and mozzarella sticks
do anything yet they make them here yeah
I have that how can I put this all in a
sandwich and I have two eggs over easy
with the side of bacon and one pancake
breezy thank you
Oh chicken pot pie please Timmy also
what do you think she knew I was drunk
no of course not
waiter more spoons please oh speaking of
spoons
yeah what I just got a craving for hell
me okay I'm four words movie camera
isn't that 7-eleven yes mm-hmm
how do you feel I feel like I want hot
dogs
yeah keep over right here so this is me
wait this is in and out yeah I see a
tomorrow Kinney give me a burger or
something a double-double with extra
onions and the secret sauce